I just think it she's finding it hard to
understand why someone like me would
vote for someone like him right it's
hard it's weird I don't know how to
explain it so luckily with Julia my name
is Kelsey and I voted for Hillary
Clinton today I came here with Dean and
Dina's my neighbor I was in the United
States Army I served for five years and
I voted for Donald Trump my name is
Vanessa and I voted for Hillary I'm here
today with my boyfriend Jose I voted for
Donald Trump so we're here to talk about
Hillary and Donald Donald yeah what a
guy
yeah he's your guy no he's a guy he's a
guy the decision to vote for Trump was
probably the most difficult voting
decision I've ever made in my entire
life I don't like Trump as a human being
I didn't make my actual decision on who
to vote for really until day of I I
didn't sleep that night what made you to
vote for Trump after we were oh yay
family
I felt really great going in the day
voting for Hillary and we needed the
change I need to be some women power
there when I found out my boyfriend had
voted for Trump
I was stream ly pissed I told you the
whole shebang about like you know what I
know about him and you read was or you
watch a documentary you know everyone
exactly I knew so much more before the
day I decided to vote for Donald Trump
because he has a new fresh eye into
politics he actually cares for this
country because he's like a super
American he's like more proud of America
than he is of anything in the world
Vaness and I kind of talked about it but
I kind of like you didn't tell me at all
who voted for at the booth I was trying
to avoid
argument I had to find out when he was a
little bit tipsy when we were with our
friends that he actually voted for Trump
I was so hurt I get that you voted for
Trump you cared about his economic plans
and the hard thing for me of what I
don't get some of the stuff that he said
when it came to like women or when it
came to just like other groups of people
I've never been a woman in America I
couldn't tell you not to be offended by
the things that he said Kelsey and I are
similar in a lot of ways but different
in a lot of ways she's from the Midwest
I'm actually from New York but I lived
in Texas for seven years I don't like
his rhetoric I don't like the things
that he said about women but you never
agree with 100% of everything that your
candidate believes when there are
policies that Bush or Romney or you know
McCain suggested that I wasn't
necessarily on board with but I didn't
feel offended by them that's what my
show us on weekly understand what you
don't understand is that he's a
celebrity so he's gonna like so you can
be on the whole okay listen to me listen
she's so confident in what she believes
in she's like really I like on it oh I
know as Trump is not good you only think
he's not good because of what he said
they were talking about Hispanics and
how he's so racist in earth and where
Hispanic he mutant every word I don't
think so I know that he did make you
know some comments that were not they
were nice but I'm very open-minded I was
laughing about it I was like this guy is
so dumb he's just a celebrity he says
like certain things in order to create
ratings and in order to create suspense
my friends are like getting harassed
because of Trump you know I would never
do that I mean I wouldn't talk to people
the way he talks to people I don't like
Hillary the fact that she's done some of
the things that she's done the emails on
her private server I mean let's not
pretend like that's not a big deal I
volunteered for her in Los Angeles she
seemed like somebody who is going to
keep progressing us forward especially
in terms of social issues I totally get
where you're coming from because you
have that military experience and that's
why I like to talk to you about
Stephanie says to John McCain oh I like
people who don't get caught and like is
this the man that like the Republican
Party believes is like the best
representative I mean obviously I was
frustrated too the thing for me it just
went so far other beyond like all the
rhetoric that was coming out of both
sides and I just did my best to try to
see past that and see what I thought the
Republican America would look like over
the next four to eight years
pose to what the Democratic Hillary
Clinton America would look like it is
hard because even now like they even say
he doesn't even know what he's doing on
the chair like he didn't know what he
was getting himself into and like it is
just a mess she knew everything he knows
nothing
did he give me almost any other woman
who was qualified I would have been much
more open to having that discussion I'm
not saying Hillary needs to be in prison
I'm not gonna run around with a Hillary
for prison sticker on my truck you know
that I won't for me to talk to him from
the perspective of you know being a
female might help him learn about issues
with women's health and with women's
rights that you know maybe just aren't
something he thinks about in his day to
day life I do think for a lot of people
myself included I did not vote for
Hillary Clinton because she was a woman
but it definitely seemed like she
understood women's issues a lot more
than Donald even just on a policy level
what you're saying is like because women
are I guess nervous that chump is gonna
roll back right so if you want to hear
what I'm concerned about like in terms
of women's issues some different aspects
that were covered by Obamacare
potentially would be rolled back and
then as far as like you know the Supreme
Court justice picks admitted that he
would be comfortable with electing
people who were okay with overturning
roe v wade I'm a Republican I identify
with Republicans I do tend to lean more
toward like the middle at the end of the
day I had to align myself with my party
and have faith that they're not gonna
let him do crazy things when he's in
office as far as the Supreme Court
justices in roe v wade that's I can't as
a hat there's a guy like I can't tell
you not to be worried about that or how
to feel anything I could possibly
understand how you feel yeah it's like
scary yeah that's one of those things I
mean I can just kind of be a friend to
be there for you she knows who I am and
she knows that ultimately if I made a
mistake or if something like bad is
happening I will do whatever I can to
help the situation glad that we get to
get it off her chest I do know Hosea the
way he's saying it's just that little
like that little one little percenter he
like question like what wait what the
[ __ ] is going on if something crazy
happening you were put at risk like I
would be the first one standing there
next you did a fight that same battle
with you because all the matters like
rights human rights matter I never said
that I didn't agree
you know he's cocky arrogant but I said
at least you know since it's already
happening you know might as well just
like go along with it kind of like when
you go to the doctor and they tell you
you have like cancer and you have like
six months to live what are you gonna do
like the best thing to do is just like
try to do the best you can if you're
somebody who else strongly about this
political election and have people that
you care about in your lives that you
want to talk to about it
I think it's important to find out where
they came from and researched their
perspective voice your opinion for one
we're already in this and the best thing
we can do is help each other support
each other I don't really think it's
worth the arguments in the fights
because at the end of the day you're not
going to be able to change anything the
only thing you can change is your
relationships it's tough to get
perspective if you don't put yourself in
that environment to have those
conversations you can't be afraid to
have these conversations because
conversation is what what sparks change
but I get to sit down and so my eyes get
open and I get a better perspective of
things it's what drives our nation
forward she begged up banging cake I was
about to go get some of this cake hi
Hilary face all over it she didn't let
me have any of the cake cuz I ate it all
was it because I kept it from me